welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and oh me my lucifer has
now come to an end the sixth and final
season has a lot to unpack from it and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the story ending and also
what we should take from it i don't want
to waste any of your time but obviously
this video needs a big spoiler alert on
it so check out if you haven't checked
it out yet if you enjoy the breakdown
then please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this each and every day without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into lucifer season six
okay so season five part two ended with
lucifer getting a promotion after
telling chloe that he loved her lucy
beat his brother michael and took the
position of god now we pick up with him
on the eve of ascending to the silver
city and it's clear he's been getting
hot feet as he's been constantly putting
off the new role mirroring this both
maze and eve decide that they want to
remain on earth instead of going to hell
and the pair get engaged very early on
this leaves the spot wide open for a new
character to take over who becomes
somewhat of a nega sonic teenage warhead
in lucifer's life now i just want to
focus on this storyline for the first
part of the video but we will be
touching upon the other plot lines
towards the end and yeah there is a lot
to talk about i don't know if you can
hear but my nose is a bit blocked at the
moment and that's because i've just been
crying after watching the finale i mean
i mean i wasn't crying yet
there was some dust in the room now the
season ends with lucifer actually
returning to hell and rather than
accepting god's place in heaven he
builds a home there helping people
alongside his partner chloe season five
told us that it was impossible to be god
and to love someone and thus lucifer
kind of gets the best of both worlds as
he's with her and also healing lost
souls we know that the souls of the
damned are stuck there because of their
feelings of guilt but season 5 showed
that it was possible for those trapped
to ascend to heaven dan becomes a
paramount character which showcases this
as he of course died last time and
throughout the season we watch as he
tries to escape the confines of
purgatory so that he can get into heaven
thus lucifer doing this is actually
kinder than what he would be doing if he
had of ascended he's very much saving
lost souls and though he was initially
supposed to be doing this in the silver
city it makes way more sense to have him
in the underworld carrying out an action
that will save everyone those people are
of course trapped there and there was no
way for god to bring them up as it would
be against free will therefore it's
better for everyone that lucifer just
sort of coaches them along as we
predicted in our season 5 video a many
deal actually ends up becoming god but
he puts new measures in place that will
remove the mystery from the mysterious
ways the angels will now walk amongst
the humans in order to see your
behaviors firsthand which will make them
carry out their tasks better overall now
how we get there is quite an interesting
journey and we see the idea of parental
relationships brought up quite a lot
after seeing one side of a magician
double that get murdered we learned that
the culprit was one of their sons
angered that he wasn't allowed to take
over the legacy and sell it off to
netflix they are looking for shows at
the moment so yeah you could have
probably got in there now this makes
lucifer question if he's truly worthy to
step into his father's shoes and it sets
off a whole relationship with his own
child it's sort of like poetry they
rhyme as we see that in the same way his
father was god and lucy ruled over hell
that when lucy becomes a god his
daughter aurora does too after making
somewhat of an alliance with dan the
crazy murder angel travels to earth with
him and here the truth is revealed
throughout the season we learn that
she's actually from the future and that
she's back because lucy abandoned both
her and chloe a big question hangs over
the season namely why lucifer would
leave and it becomes somewhat of a
self-fulfilling prophecy as we watch it
all play out now this idea of absent
fathers was of course murdered in his
own dad who ended up leaving his kids to
their own devices his daughter's journey
very much mirrors lucifer's when you
think about it and much like him she
journeyed from hell to our world in
order to confront her father however
whereas god abandoned his kids lucifer
states that he won't and the second half
of the season revolves around the
mystery of why he decided to go hell
even the nickname of lucy being short
for lucifer is reflected in aurora
getting her nickname rory the both of
which are of course normally used as
names of their gender opposites now we
discover lots of things about the future
namely that when chloe died that lucifer
wasn't there at her side and we actually
see this play out in the finale with
heaven not having someone on the throne
the apocalypse starts to happen judah
angels answering everyone's prayers and
making a mess of it i've been praying
that this video gets a lot of thumbs up
so yeah make sure you do that now
because of this lucifer needs to make a
choice and either stay with his daughter
or take on his duties vincent is
inadvertently freed and to make matters
worse chloe finds out she's pregnant
with rory which puts further pressure on
lucifer this all comes to a head in
episode 9 and after lucifer says his
good cries rory forgives him which
finally allows him to move on to his
next task guilt-free this is modern dan
who after possessing vincent gets a
heart to heart with his daughter and he
finally goes to heaven unfortunately
this frees vincent who kidnaps chloe and
he takes her to 10th and swanson which
is the fateful location that lucifer
disappeared the final episode called
partners till the end has a lot of
meaning and vincent ends up taking
blades from rory's wings which he turns
into a weapon leads to one of the best
action scenes in the entire series but
unfortunately chloe is stabbed in the
charge and this leads to lucifer facing
off against vincent himself we realize
that his greatest desire is to see rory
grow up and not being able to do this
will be somewhat his own personal hell
lucifer agrees to give his own life to
save her but rory breaks free calls
lucifer dad for the first time and she
goes almost full mask off mode nearly
revealing her devil face however lucifer
convinces her not to kill him so that
she doesn't go down the dark path that
he did and just before the darker side
takes over she spares vincent's life
unfortunately for him he still tries to
kill lucy one last time but chloe
arrives and then shoots him instead of
what dan saw he just witnesses darkness
and we do see him in hell for the final
few scenes although it seems like a
happy ending due to rory not
disappearing we realize that the future
hasn't been changed however the group
concluded that lucifer pointing dan in a
direction that got him into heaven
helped him a lot and this is also
reflected in rory they come to the
conclusion that her traveling back in
time was so that he could heal her and
that in hell he'll be able to do more
good lucifer is very much a character
that knows what it's like to fall and
rise and he realizes that he's been put
on this path by his father hell doesn't
need a helper it needs a healer and he
goes into the underworld in order to
save the lost souls and sinners the time
loop is very much complete with the
future having impact on the past and the
past also creating the future rory
returns to her own time and lucifer and
chloe have their final farewell for now
i'm not crying you're crying and we see
a many deal in heaven ushering forth his
new plan ella's stem initiative is
launched and dan and charlotte reunite
in the afterlife chloe returns to the
lapd amenities and linda celebrate
charlie's first birthday and to add to
the surprises he also gets his wings
maze and eve work together to take on
criminals and the group will welcome
baby rory to the world after a big time
jump we see the story that rory told us
about and join chloe on her deathbed
rory returns to this moment from the
past and thanks her mother for allowing
her to go through this journey her own
way rather than having any regrets of
guilt which is something that a lot of
people have on their death bed chloe
says she wouldn't change a thing and we
watch in the afterlife as she partners
up with lucifer we catch him in a
duplicate of linda's therapy room and he
counsels rhysgeddy who you might
remember from earlier in the series
joined by vincent we watch as he's truly
helping people and he and chloe kiss as
they start the rest of eternity together
it's the perfect way to end the season
and we close out to welcome to the black
parade by my chemical romance
this song is about a patient looking
back on his life and the memories that
he has of it death appears to him and
manifests as his happiest ones and the
lyrics we'll carry on carry a lot of
meaning as we know that this is the end
but that the characters are going on to
happier times without us really knocks
it out the park and this is an amazing
send-off for the characters now as for
the season as a whole i think this got
better the longer that it went on and
though it started off a bit slow by the
end i was sad to see it go
most of the seasons so far have had fun
episodes that sort of break the fourth
wall and whereas in the past we got
musical ones here we get a full animated
one called yabba dabba doomy drawn in
the style of a hannah barbera cartoon it
looks incredible and feels like one of
the high points in the series it's stuff
like that which is why i'm gonna be sad
to see the series go and it's a very
bittersweet finale that i hope isn't the
end
even though i know it is but but you can
always hope now juxtaposing this fun
stuff we also get way more serious plot
lines involving a mana deal as he deals
with racism and corruption within the
force dan also has a great arc too that
reminded me a lot of rannell and hopkirk
deceased in case you haven't heard of it
and i am showing my age it was a cop
sitcom from the 70s in which a
policeman's partner died and he came
back as a ghost to help his buddy solve
crimes
now though all the plot lines come
together to make a really strong
send-off i do feel that earlier parts of
the season fall into the usual murder of
the weak trope and in all honesty i just
don't find them all that interesting
clocking in at 10 hours i do think that
the show could have focused more on the
main plot points and cut down its run
time to tell a slightly swifter story i
know it dropped today but i actually got
early access to the season a couple of
weeks ago and when i think back on those
early parts they are by far the most
forgettable now the main things that
will stick with me are the sentimental
ones such as lucifer and his daughter's
relationship as well as that final
episode it does feel like the finale
that we've been wanting and it's
difficult to fault that final hour at
all i am judging the series as a whole
low but if i was just going off that
episode it would be a 10 out of 10.
however looking at the series and taking
everything into account though ended
really really well there were still some
slower parts and thus it gets an 8 out
of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you leave all the
devil in the details in the comments
below we are running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of the
zack snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the season
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now save that
to you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want to meet us to
watch them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the matrix trailer which
will be linked on screen right now we
went over the brand new look and pointed
out all the easter eggs we could find so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for singing through the video
i've been paul you take care and i'll
see you next time have a good weekend
and peace